la journée mondiale de protection des
données est l'occasion de sensibiliser
les personnes danger menace de la
cybercriminalité et les seniors sont des
cibles potentielles pour faciliter
l'accès aux nouvelles technologies et
développer l'usagé du web
plusieurs modules étaient proposés à
l'espace net public de
voisins-le-bretonneux c'est apprendre à
bien différencier tout les tout ce qu'on
peut me proposer en termes de serveurs
donc de cloud de bien protéger ses
données au niveau même de son ordinateur
smartphone tablette numérique
on a vu par exemple ne jamais laisser un
disque dur lorsqu'on jette un ordinateur
la déchetterie les données ont changé
elles vont aujourd'hui bien au-delà de
nos simples coordonnées dans un annuaire
téléphonique à l'ère du numérique les
données personnelles englobe nos
contacts nos lectures nos photos que les
seniors apprennent à gérer avec le cloud
au début que j'étais à la retraite j'ai
suivi le formation sur la photo je
comment se servir d'un ordinateur
également on a toujours des doutes quand
on doit se servir d'un réalisateur donc
on a toujours peur de mal faire mais
années qui arrivent ou nous oblige à
utiliser un ordinateur internet
il faut pas que les personnes de plus de
60 ans soit laissé sur le gros du côté
du chemin parce qu'ils ne seront pas
utilisées pour vous recevoir des et news
que ce soit d or acc que ça soit des du
fichier et les personnes âgées sont des
victimes potentielles
d'autres ateliers sont proposés jusqu'au
14 février plus de 2,5 milliards
d'octets de données sont créés chaque
jour